[Music]
on this episode of travel dares
nico and i are going to learn how to
ride penny farthing bicycles
push push push pull up
and i'm taking caroline to cambridge
university where we're going to learn
how to punt
i was born to turn this punch around
come join us on our adventures on this
episode of travel dares
this is travel dares the show where we
do daring activities all over europe
empowered by my marriott bombay
boundless card london is one of the most
popular travel destinations in the
entire
world but today we're going to be doing
two dares that are a bit more off the
beaten path
nico you're going first let's see this
clue
let's go back in time these crews are
just getting more and more vague
my mind is going to like making candles
or churning butter or something maybe
we're making clogs
we're turning back time kenny farthing
bicycles were invented in england in the
19th century
london's penny farthing club lets you
see the city on these huge antique bikes
so close so close okay all right now you
stand right here okay nico take your
blindfold off
because we're riding penny farthing
bicycles all around town
wait these old bicycles i've never seen
one of these in person it's huge
so the penny farthing bicycle actually
called an ordinary bicycle was invented
in 1869 and became quite popular in
central london
everyone loves to see us ride the bikes
and the eight foot tall
up in the air you get a really fantastic
view of all the great sights the penny
filing bike tour is a three-hour
experience the first half of the
experience is learning to safely and
competently and confidently ride the
bicycle
and then we go on a guided tour of
central london seeing all the great
sights of westminster
[Music]
what i'll do is i'll demonstrate first
okay and then it'll be your turn
oh gosh is there like training wheels we
can put on the bike
uh certainly not so this is how it looks
in in real life
push push push pop up up
i can't make it look so easy
okay i turn the corner straight line i
want to get off
come down the peg and hop off like so
thank you
guys
slide onto the seat nice and relaxed yep
and you're in charge of steering
oh no i'm trying not to freak out right
now
you're doing it you're doing good
get off and then just melt
stand up on the next peg just relax i'm
a little short
my feet keep slipping from the petals
oh god well done
let's go my heart was pounding i thought
i was
a goner
[Music]
yeah we did it congratulations you're
both penny farthing riders
time to put our training to the test
let's get the wheels rolling
riding yay
wow i think we're really getting the
hang of it i think so too
out of the way i can't stop we are free
riding
down the road down these english roads
i'm glad we're doing it together
mikko we rode all the way to the london
eye without falling no we didn't fall at
all which is all i wanted
yeah now it's time for the queue there
you go
ready study up give me your thoughts oh
my god give me your thoughts
i'm getting like a few things popping in
my head like books
school magic um i hope we're not taking
a test because i'm not a good test taker
hunting is the number one thing to do
here at cambridge you get to see
all these amazing sites of the
university right on the water
and i can't wait to show caroline i feel
like we're at a farm or something okay
stop right here okay take off your
blindfold
because we're at cambridge university
and we're about to go punting
in these boats punting yeah i've never
even heard of that
i am super stoked i really want to learn
how to do this ready to go
yeah let's do it i literally can't wait
to sit back and chill while caroline
punts me all over cambridge
i'm so like relaxed already like i'm
just chilling well punting was
originally used for transporting goods
across the river from
cambridge to ely to be a good punty
definitely you could need good sea legs
need good balance otherwise you might
find yourself in the water
look at that oh my god that's king's
college chapel right now
king's college chapel all right caroline
what do you think your technique is
going to be
um i'm just going to try to keep like a
lot of pressure on my legs
and then trust the trust the pool
and like to guide me straight there you
go
and you just want to pick it up like
this drop it in and just push
okay ready perfect perfect now quick
push caroline
that might be
[Applause]
all right where do you guys want to go
in cambridge you want to go to class
you're taking us for a spin yeah we're
going for a spin
buckle up i was born to turn
this cut around guys i am punting in
heels
that doesn't get me an extra star i
don't know what will
uh oh well never mind i lost that really
oh
we're going to crash a little here
sorry sorry that's my bad
don't fall off i'll try
i think i'm john frederick i'm going to
give this back to you let me save you
caroline you did it
[Music]
nico i had such an amazing time in
london it's literally so beautiful
especially from the hotel you can see
the river thames
the london eye it's so amazing it's a
gorgeous view
niko penny farthing is not an easy thing
to do
it takes a bit of skill to learn
everything but you got
on you rode all the way around town and
you didn't fall
and for that you are getting a 5 out of
5
stars five stars on this i did not think
it was gonna happen
i was so scared i was gonna fall the
whole time
caroline i'm gonna start off by saying
how much i love you
nico and how much i appreciated your
enthusiasm and your energy when we went
out punting
but there has to be a butt
but we did spend more time going in
circles than we did
getting anywhere so i think i'm gonna
have to give you
a solid four star okay solid four
i will take that cambridge was
absolutely beautiful it was gorgeous so
i
really didn't mind going in circles that
much we got 360 views yeah
mikko we have just a few more hours left
in london so let's hit the town
cheers cheers